[Music]
oh
[Music]
this
[Music]
um
and a few good breaths to start it on
get into this place
the already always free and perfect
[Music]
roommate you were gonna say something
it's even in the name god
maybe it's silent
do you want to know something you want
to know something man i was
born on hanuman genti and it's my
birthday
it was my birthday yesterday today so
and there's something
there again a little synchronicity
tidbit for you
those connections man those that web is
just too
deep it's just too rich man the tapestry
is just too
delightful
as the tapestry unfolds itself in front
of you
what's your relationship with time
around this
revolution
yeah the world is like a big big big
pain
painting itself all the time
and the canvases
the canvas is just
the canvas means the paint as much as
the paint
brings out the canvas
that's a good one that's a good i've
really enjoyed
the analogies that help people
realize infinity because
how many different ways can you arrange
musical notes into a song
how many different ways can you arrange
images into a movie
how many different ways can you arrange
food into recipes
and especially what you just said is
that
we're actually making the chicken soup
and eating it
too they're making each the process is
making each other
and that's a good one because if earth
if this universe the civilization
is a chicken soup
the next creation will be a beet salad
and the next one will be steak and
potatoes and
etc yeah you'll never come to the end of
all
combinations flavors man the
flavors and even the scientists the
mathematicians the logicians
have proven girdle and so many others
have pointed at this
and wittgenstein you'll never come to
the end
of all combinations of math ever and so
that's what this
is spirituality's been saying it for
thousands of years
so bring the two together we're done
and we got infinite amount of chefs
we're just throwing in
oh a little bit of salt here it's out
there chili there
yeah we're all making it i'm eating it
we're all loving it because we're all
making it for each other
we're cooking up spell casters dude
spellcaster
we're mixing it up the board
i mean i don't i don't even know when
that whole rap thing
um that whole whatever that was that was
when that began and when it ends
up oh you and she well dude it's just
it's been like
you know yeah everybody there was a
whole thing that happened earlier
tonight
before uh before you before you joined
the call um
we were all oh yeah you heard about it
we were gonna make the the band and
everything
and i was saying like you know that
just it's like exactly what you say the
sprinkle of salt
and pepper and chili and mate and
you know french fries and just sounds
and textures and it's like
i think the compassion comes in where
you realize that you're making the soup
for all
others to eat too you're keeping the
eater
in mind as you're creating the food you
know
that's what makes good food yeah
all the time and the thing is like
that's when the understanding comes in
is because when people recognize that um
especially when people recognize like
insecurities and things like that
that's when people are like hey man like
you know
this is not never a hindrance in the
first place
you know this is like your
[Music]
it's your play it's your
yes i have an an extension of the
analogy
on episode two with frank yang he's been
perpetuating the cosmic octopus
right yeah yes so the the cosmic octopus
is the one god self the one witness the
one observer the one seer the one
awareness the all-inclusive awareness
and that each of us are adding the
spices
in the cosmic octopus chef that's
cooking it cosmically
and were these eight billion tentacles
that are both
in taking the food as well as cooking
the food so yeah paint yeah it's it was
kind of a
little bit of an interesting synthesis
have you guys seen it's a it's a it's an
ever flowing synthesis dude
yes it's the the synthesis and the d
synthesis
are just the you know it's never
like rare you know
i kind of want to open up into that
analogous
g because i don't feel like the octopus
has a center or a body
oh yeah the tendrils yeah
but the whole thing is the center of the
thing yeah yeah
perfect
this it's it's so um mind-bending
as the singular sphere of locating the
center of yourself becomes the whole
sphere
you see that
there's there's no words for it because
words
create the boundary of the of the wiggle
wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle
so now we just echo about expansion
this is this is a pretty interesting way
to put
awakening as the series of expansions in
the series of dissolving
and that process of the nothingness to
everythingness and then that
being that very cosmic octopus without
an eye the eye is
so intoxicative and so
illusory but it's the it's the most
important aspect to
our creation because there has to be the
power to know so it's both the crown
attribute and it's the crown assumption
at the same time
yes bring bring that in brandon bring
that in
the one who forgets the one who
remembers the two sides of the infinity
symbol
for those that are just on audio love
that one
and the ebb and flow between those
states of remembering and forgetting
see i i ignorance isn't forgetting
the joy is renewed until you recognize
that
the remembering and the forgetting are
also
you can't there's no the remembering and
forgetting you could never have one
without the other
it isn't forgetting that the joy is
renewed yep
there you go
that's when the laughter comes in that's
when the cosmic joke is like
[Laughter]
that's what the universe is like [ __ ]
hell dude
this whole time that's
[Laughter]
thanks for the comment it
quantum is is the name yeah that's the
sick name yeah
you know this is interesting is that
dualistic concession
is really important that's why the tiju
that has both the monist and the yin
yang within it is so
critical because it's both there is
nobody
that asleep ins and then awakens
and so that's that well do you had a
[ __ ] image for it a thousand years
ago that everybody forgot about which is
the taijitsu
and so it's also plastered all over
other cultural traditions
yeah this is it
oh you mean the okay well yeah
but you see the the key with the
taijitsu
is that it is both the monist and
it's the yin yang in one symbol
and the the old school representation of
it
this one over here on the left the old
school representation of it
it actually has more of an ascensionary
component to it a cyclic yet
ascensionary
that that they interplay at a
more playful sort of
yeah and then ties into the eight
trigrams and aspects of
nature it feels
to me it's the dna man it's the helix
it's this it's the dna
yeah it's the constant going up going up
going up going up
yeah also going down going down hi guys
i'll show you guys an image that like i
think correlates with this
of course yes
[Applause]
yep yeah so there's the taijitsu and
then the oro boros
which i literally made last year
enjoying it
yeah go ahead i like how the tai chi
created
the impermanent cycle and the time wave
cone and it's really hard to
simultaneously
visualize those because that breaks
conceptual thinking
but they they isolated it in a symbol
which is
kind of like the maha mudra great symbol
that you were holding with the
two things elmo it's like
the vadra yeah the mudra yeah yeah yeah
that's what it called for sure
dude i wanna i wanna
and uh it just did something to me dude
i don't even know what it was but just
just holding it in my hands and just
like running it through my
uh between my fingers just i don't know
why
108 it just does something dude
[Music]
what was the key of the
pull it up
v-a-d-r-a
uh j v-a-j-r-a
and that's the that's like the symbol
of the third buddhist path because after
mahayana
comes the vajrayana
dude i'm looking to get some vagina
tattoos man
oh yeah oh for sure you want her the
artwork is insane man the clouds and the
whole
the deities and [ __ ] man it's so
beautiful
that is so rich like when you just dive
into it
it's volumes the vajra is a sanskrit
word meeting
both thunderbolt and diamond
it's like the thunder enlightenment that
comes like
yeah awakens you this [ __ ]
burst you open and the dying
symbolizes the indestructibility of
dharma
and truth the indestructibility of
dharma
will be ineffable
[Music]
because known as the great vehicle
and so that's what they're the diamond
vehicle the dharma and the thunderbolt
is the
that's cool you know the pants uh
hinayana small vehicle uh mahayana a
great vehicle
they're kind of just preparatory steps
for the adriana
because that's where you actually get to
live again
yeah yeah that's when you get together
you kind of restrict it
you just call it you expand
you get back into the world but vagina
just you just
become whatever you are and your being
is
beautified you become
so is the great zog chin solution
in a tractor
attractive yes yeah
it is so the great vehicle
aka also can be thought of as like sufi
metaphysics or as
theravada buddhism any any sort of
advice of a danta
these can totally be thought of
attractors as attractors
yeah even even anthogens are attractors
magic mushrooms i would say something
though
psychedelic means mind manifesting but
anthogen means
unleashing god within the divine within
and so that's why entheogen is just a
more clean word for it
it's more precise it's like precision
you know precision yeah i dig that
because there
can be two ways of taking those
substances
just tripping and
awakening the symbiotic relationship
yes yes
the life force synergy with
the plant your life for
sinking with it creating something new
okay
nice he looks right yeah that helix that
dances with itself
one enemy but when you've got whatever
anti-aging you have
the other end it's you one end is god
the other end is you
and then it's only when to just one
stick
yeah and then what the dancing begins it
recognizes just one little
yo weren't we just talking about that
thing elmo
that lightning in the something yeah
what is it lightning and what diamonds
yeah
thunderbolt and diamond under bolton
diamond yeah
and then there's the bell which the
other symbol and the bell
and the vajra symbolized elmo those are
charged up
bro these are charged up items i can see
it
and skillful application
so you got wise action
enlightened activity
[Music]
yeah give us a little bit on that again
on the fajr so the vajra is a symbol
for the way that the dharma hits you
when it really hits you
it's like you're just walking out on the
field
minding your own business not even
meditating
and the truth hits you
but you don't die
it's like getting a blessing from
[ __ ] zeus
you just you get hit with the lightning
but you don't die so you know you're
kinda you got something
out of that experience even though it
might like zap you
and hurt you you still got it
you received it and that's it man the
lightning
leaves a it leaves a mark
and it leaves a mark on uh
for anybody who is working with energy
you know it can feel like a lightning
coming from like within going into all
your cells running it's because it's
electromagnetic
and the bell is the magnetic part
so you have the vajra which is kind of
masculine the bell which is kind of
feminine
um
but they're just symbols you know well
they're they're also
they're symbols but they're also
attractors they're kind of like the
divine
symbols really they're like
our most divine symbols they're our most
divine
pedagogies if you want to know
how to turn inward and recognize
nothingness and infinity
and even babystep yourself to awareness
and then to this nothingness and
infinity
if you want to know your true nature
you may as well you're going to get
gravitated it's actually
not possible for you to not become aware
of advaita vedanta and zokchen and there
varmus or sufi metaphysics
all of the main mystic traditions you'll
at least
learn about one of them and many people
end up learning about two three four
five
because what they're trying to do is or
all of them because what they're trying
to do is they're trying to abstract out
a meta pattern
of what is the most optimal way
to look at the very one end
that's where i came from the last year
was this meta pattern angle
to it and i would say that that's
probably the greatest
quality of my
conceptual lattice work is the fact that
it's
carries many different traditions and
concepts
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you're just
that's right
that's why one here
one there it's beautiful it's it's a
prism it gets the light and it
reflects it all realizing the located
godhead of the one end is realizing
the toroidal field
realizing godhead equals realizing
toroidal field
how it moves is the way the down moves
oh yeah
oh yeah at the same time it's going in
yeah and it's going out yeah and when
it's going out it's going in adam's
onion it's going out it's going out it's
going in
everything that's why the greatest
symbols are
us man and woman
yeah why do you think why do you think
you are rihanna
why do you think vagina was willing to
to make sex like part of
part of the spiritual path like and
that's why i was gonna say earlier too
like i feel like
um anthogens and um
antiogens and and uh zucchin and vagina
specifically as an attractor
i feel like just for our generation
specifically
like our you know just
like if you just look at all the
creatives at our
age um like
on earth right now humanity at this time
just what's popular and what's hip and
what's cool is
actually what's getting people to wake
up you know
and and if people were to just follow
you know it's like
i think i think stockman said it like
liquefying into your passions
that's what happens to people is like
once they liquify
that's when you know it hits you and
it's just the
the liquid just doesn't in this end
right and it's so and it's like whether
it be through anthogens
and vajrayana and like looking at that
art um
photography and all of these things
aperture in and out
you know it's it's it's having that
movement and that play and that dance
with
uh everything with every aspect of
whatever it is you've liked and disliked
and loved and hated and everything
and being able to move with any of that
with anyone anywhere is what
is it's it's like right there in every
single you know
every breath of every battle of every
dandruff piece falling off your hair
and even that into the soil and into the
into the blade of grass with the sun
reflecting
off it and and you know
where is that light is that light inside
your inside your eye
is it the the kaleidoscope inside your
inside that eyeball
where is that light
it's always just portal and something
going in
coming up the other end black holes
white holes
increasingly fractal and granular me and
gotcha having this conversation
one arm five arms fractals
this is what it is this is what it is
like a tree growing
and the roots are equally used there we
go
and welcome thank you we're back
welcoming all zen buddhists and uh
um vajrayana practitioners and infinite
bras
and atmospheres everybody's psychedelics
and all the
waters everywhere and all corona viruses
everything everybody welcome
[Music]
earlier elmo said that the fractal is
moving
in you and you're moving in the fractal
that was really visceral
immediately
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is what we're doing is we're
actually working on making the
the nature of reality disseminated to
the masses
in the most immersive experience as
possible
yeah which is really exciting frank's
also really passionate about that we'll
potentially be doing that in the fall
together and so you guys are all doing
that yourselves as well on your channels
and your platforms is
and this is why this zen fam is so
strong is because
the that's what's bringing our hearts
together is the truth
and visualizing it and disseminating it
and serving other people's awakenings
i think jason silver was trying to do
something so similar
i don't know i remember he had spoken
about like a
like a movie experience like in the
theater
they sit down and literally get
enlightened with
[Music]
i think he was working on like some
thing you could put on your head and it
would give you the
correct brain waves yeah that it would
emulate the
state of samadhi because it is brain
waves that's what i was going to say is
that
the the reason that uh that these things
work
and the reason like i would i would you
know i had a i was
i was i was on this sfdc call once and
um um and
we were reading some uh mahayana sutra
and
just this conversation just started and
it just kept going and going and going
and i recognized that you know the
reason in buddhism they have like the
three the three jews
you know the buddha the dharma the
sangha it's
these are just words but what they
represent is
is you know it's it's having that um
it's because of the fractalization it's
because of that liquefying and it's
because of that echo
that those three jewels
are three jewels you know it's like your
your most treasured
it it's it's the
you know the trinity of
it's the north star yeah for me
it's the three characteristics
anata are the reflections
of the three jewels
so you got the no self the reflection of
that
is the universal self
yeah you got the
uh dharma which could be the
okay so to me dharma is factoriness the
dharma is perfect
so that is the balancing side of the
suffering samsara nirvana and then
there's the
i don't know which reflects which but
you know you get it it's the
star of david again and
the impermanence is like the
the impermanence is like the knot
that ties that suffering and no self
together impermanence is like
it's like the the wake up call you know
impermanence and seeing like water like
the axis of the two
um yeah yeah it's only because of
impermanence that you can have
you know but to have movement of the two
you must have
that hub of the wheel
to have movement you must have a hub
and that's the balancing point
that's my where there is no masculine no
feminine just the movement
even getting people to that go go for it
go for it and come guys yeah
coming into that balancing point
no matter who you lost you can always
find your
way back into it because that is the
center
less center and you yes
we all know the direction and the path
there that's our shared heart
yeah that's the place where we actually
meet
not through our thoughts and
yeah that's where we meet yeah
it's the source right it's like the it's
the source it's just that
shinzon diagram of just this this little
thing in here and it's just
a space and time just going around it
and he's like oh just abide in the
unborn
light in the unborn and you know it's
unborn is it this one
yeah that's it that's it wow
activity of the source perfect
i have to say man i think i think
shenzhen the only reason he got so deep
into his meditation
it has to be because of all the wheat he
used to smoke dude
has to be dude
this guy i think i know him
oh yo that's the dude man i know that
dude
he is amazing dude he's awesome dude
he's so
i don't know him such grounded dharma
yeah
it's like he you know it's like he's
standing on that heap of jewels
but he's not above you he's so he's so
yeah exactly
exactly normal yeah
dude i was so lucky like i got to i got
to talk with him just for like a short
duration
um yeah yeah and just like it was insane
man i told him like hey look this is
where i'm at right now in my practice
like i don't have you know
i have no clue what the [ __ ] is going on
and i'm like you know
it just feels like all parts flying
loose and
but at the same time they're not it's
like i know where i am but i don't know
where i am at the same time and vladimir
and then he's like and then i described
it to him and
all i said was you know i just i just i
keep recognizing
that as soon as i hear something it's
known before i even move there
and so i don't have to move there and
i and i just told him he's like
yeah i was like you know where
what now and he's just he's just burst
burst out laughing he's like what now
that's the question to be answered is
what now
and that's the thing like to me it's
like the the character is
um you know like frank has said it hanzo
has said it so many times i think
everybody has experienced it after
having
had some sort of like either a a
life-changing trip
or just a really deep samadhi where as
soon as you come out of it you're like
[ __ ] what happens now and it's i think
for me
for me personally like adriana and all
of that and embracing the outer
experience
is where the the the character
and the align in that atlas yeah that's
where they meet that's really
important to the activity of the source
yep
yeah aligning your activity
perfection yeah
and uh after enlightenment the dishes
all right let me hit let me hit some
tennis balls so
what you can say the activity of the
source
is is it's the gps callback
functionality
inward towards the black hole and it's
the fire working
endlessly outward as unique expressions
and so we've refined this human vehicle
over creations to be able to create the
style of
lila that actually happens as a bunch of
love light
and so it took a long time to get this
neurobiology
yeah and so then what happens is most
people go
out as fireworks first because honestly
the attractor to go
outward is really strong because
going inward you end at the same place
every time
it's a different way in but it ends at
the same place
but outward is different every time
that's why people love going outwards so
much because it's different
every single time and so there's
endless fireworking that's eternally
different
form and different creativity because
that's we are the inexhaustible
creativity
but the activity of source outward
people are more attracted to
which is why there's so much
self-actualization and self-development
and self-help literature and psychology
local focus on that versus
the inward the inward is critical with
the activity of the source because every
time somebody tries to fire work outward
they get intoxicated by maya and so they
end up
getting they go for their firework but
they're doing it to try and extract
peace and happiness from the creation
but you'll never get it from the
creation
you'll always have the watch or the car
or the experience the relationship
whatever it is
will never fully satisfy the only way to
fully satisfy is to become aware that
the nature of the observer itself
is peace and happiness and then so
that's why
going inward itself the activity of the
source going inward
is what enables the fire working
outward to be in full-fledged
harmony with the creation in your
service
and then and then
the reason that you can't say vajrayana
is separate from
theravada and all of this stuff and you
know how frank's
expansion and contraction is because
when you go out and you look into
phenomena
and you really look into it that's when
you see that what either you're going in
or going out
it's the same place you're going to
right which is why it's
it's it's every time you remember that
oh it's a dream it's an illusion
and it's just you know as soon as you
start feeling your fingers and you can
notice that
the depth and the richness in there
that's when you recognize oh my group is
coming from the very same place all the
time constantly on and on and over and
over again
which is when you know you're taking a
[ __ ] and it's like you're in heaven
[Laughter]
but this so there's there's more to this
point that's that's really interesting
actually it has to do with the image
that we didn't get to talk about too
much that showed up which is the
immersed klein bottles as well
so you know felix klein and again
mathematicians and geometricians
and scientists have for the longest time
mobius stripping
or m.c escher with art have been trying
to
point us in this direction that
spirituality has also been pointing to
for the longest time which is the
infinite go ahead yeah
can i intercept um shout out to dr
veselyn junich
mobius strick mobius strip mobius strip
uh disseminator investment unit
hotline university how do i spell it
vessel in junick
sfu simon fraser university university
v-e-s-l-i-n um
here i'll else i'm not sure exactly but
i'll find it and tell you okay yeah send
it to me and in
in in the meanwhile
this stuff is mission critical for
visualizing the nature
as well if you get the taste that the
nature
is
it's uh j-u-n-g-i-c wrestling
j-u-n-g-i-c
j-u-n-j-i-c and
dude this is so critical like i was i'm
sorry
while you're searching this up you know
this conversation is so critical
especially
in the private chat center in the
private chat oh yeah
so yeah this like just just
the this whole thing i said about like
the microphone phenomenology and at the
same time
you know being able to expand and
contract like frank puts it amazingly
where he says
you know step one uh contract step two
expand step three be able to do both
uh step four be able to do that while
you're drinking milk yeah or trying to
you know
and it's like uh to to me it's
like my experience with this when i
first had it
was i was i was walking on campus and i
was just i
basically it was like i think to me
enlightenment is like controlled
psychosis
in a lot of ways that's what it is
and and so it's like and you recognize
like your sanity is a privilege as well
like your sanity is not something like
it's also a creation just like anything
else
and to be able to connect is a very
important
it's one of those skillful means type of
things and so for me
sanity is the basic
yes yes that's that's so the base yep
yeah
and self illuminating like
the nature of mind is sane yeah
but it can twist itself into a not think
it's insane
but it's still safe it's not saying yeah
and that's the thing like i was i was on
campus and i was like just
i didn't understand it at all and my
thought process was just completely
broken
and i recognized like whatever i was
thinking it was true in the moment
as it was going on but i was drawing
connections that were just so
like unseen unthinkable that i was like
okay this is not
you know i'm just i don't even know
what's going on like is this solipsism
is this non-duality where where is the
where is the what you know and so so i'm
walking around campus and i'm just
sitting there and i started looking at
these rocks
and i i sat at this bench
i hadn't done anything anything
whatsoever like no drugs nothing i'm
just sitting there
okay and it was after i had had some
sort of like glimpse
um and i'm just sitting at the bench and
just the sunlight and everything and i'm
like okay i'm just gonna not go to my
class right now
and just just see where this these
trains of thoughts go
and i just noticed moment by moment like
how you know depending on what it was
that i was recognizing and
depending on the connections i was
drawing for myself or for others
it was visceral in the moment what i saw
where the shadows went on their face if
i saw beauty on their face
that's what they saw in themselves too
if i put divinity on their face they saw
divinity on themselves too
and they came from divinity it wasn't
like i put it on them it was the very
fact that
they themselves just had the place to
bring it out and it's not like i did it
right it's just i was open just whatever
in
whatever i was doing it just happened
and it was
in that that i recognized just looking
back on it is that people have this all
the time when they
people have this all the time when
they're just like um
you know look at a look at a blade of
grass and you just dig deeper and deeper
and deeper into it and you just see
those neurons and
you know where like you the neurons like
the
the hair on your hand the grass yeah the
hair on the head
the grass on the floor the carpet on the
the sock on your foot
the cap on your head the beard on your
chin
it's all ecstasy for those that are
subtle enough to detect
that it's all ecstasy which is why step
one and step
two you really gotta be vigilant
with not falling into the crevices of
psychosis
and then stabilizing as a normie and
then disseminating and further
catalyzing awakening
and as you do that that the sort of
ecstasy will fill your every single
experience the entire
creation is in itself ecstasy
it is yeah that yet
the universal background omnipresent
undercurrent of ecstasy can't
be heard for those with a noisy mind
that was all of our first step it's
everyone's first step
you have to quiet the mind man it's the
recognition that the noise isn't even
noise
that's the point the quote i posted
i think that's perfect for this put it
put it in the private chat
and then i did
the moment noise becomes noise
it is just
it's almost it's ejaculated instead of
ejaculated i hear what you're saying
like the undercurrent the first thought
of love
is the granular warmth ecstasy that
atlas is talking about
and adding to ramen's cascade
it's no noise it's all pervasive no
noise is every noise
yeah no noise is every noise
i wouldn't i wouldn't say or experience
that the
nature of the all-pervasive background
is ecstasy bliss
but the granular awareness incepts at
the first thought of love
at ecstasy bliss
yeah so the big bang is just a
explosion of love
okay well then let's play with that a
little bit more because if you were
technically
abiding in the all-inclusive awareness
or the one god
self perpetually then you would be bliss
ecstasy peace
but because you still and i still and
all of us still
undergo a process of of course
correcting to
that realignment with the pure love
light
that way we're not we don't because
everything that we talk about regarding
oh it's not the undercurrent it's
because
we get attached to some sort of a
thought cloud that appears
or a layer of conditioning i have lack
right now i'm feeling
a need that needs to be validated by
other fireworks
or else i can't be happier peaceful but
if we abide perpetually repeatedly
non-stop until it becomes 100
home which is sachinrananda
then that's when where that's why it's a
perpetual process it's not a one and
done
boom done it's like oh well i get it
and now there's an abiding process and
it deepens over time and that's
beautiful
but once you get it you can't lose it
yeah let's let's let's unpack with rome
god trip where you at
um i've had so many
different glimpses man of all kind of
different [ __ ]
but i feel like in my everyday life i
kind of go back like i'm i'm
i've let go of almost every concept i
don't give a [ __ ] about knowledge
anymore i don't care about i'm just i
just
am you know just that kind of children i
don't really think too much and i i went
from
like two months ago i was just a crazy
[ __ ] thinker all day long
what's the next step what's the key
what's the cheat code what is the
ultimate you know piece the knowledge
now i've realized
yesterday i was aware of awareness i was
very aware of
like just bodily sensations and thoughts
and everything mind period
it's just completely separate from what
i am and um
well not separate but i felt separated i
guess in the moment
but i guess i didn't get the
the explosion i still haven't had the
explosion but i have had
very weird glimpses i guess i'm feeling
one with everything very compassionate
um like no anger i don't get angry for
anything anymore really [ __ ] yeah
but that's where i've been i just i
haven't had
the moment and i know it's i'm chasing
it and i'm chasing it still even without
any other thoughts
that is like my only thought now just
enlightenment enlightenment
enlightenment
and that's why i've been just listening
to you guys trying to catch
patterns still like my old thought
process
and then i kind of like escaped and i
said yo god
and then i come back so i still haven't
gotten it
all the way though and i feel like
there's that little eagle that little
piece of the brain
or whatever the [ __ ] it is just jumps in
the way it's like hold on [ __ ]
like you're almost there but no look
over here you know look over here
distracting me everywhere i'm like [ __ ]
you you know i'm trying to like
but then it's like when i when i zoom
out
it's it's like looking at a video game
character
that's like fighting with himself in the
mirror and i i think it's so dumb
you know i'm like this is so stupid yeah
what you said in the chat
what you said in the chat bro you said
exactly like
how the [ __ ] am i talking to all of
these enlightened reflections of myself
and i'm still not getting it
yeah exactly from truth yeah
self-illuminating thoughts and
reflections of yourself
and there's still that small speck
that's like it's you know for me for me
it's the thought
wait wait wait can i let me hit the ball
back to rome for to gotcha because
i think it's really important that as we
make this container that we also
aim to help each other in the process
and so and so what it sounds like is
that
this process of when the perception
is kind of being brought outward right
you know it's being brought outward
you're like tennis ball pen tennis ball
pen
object object object experience thought
emotion what not
just keep bringing it back perpetually
to observing or to seeing or to
witnessing
awareness itself perpetually keep
bringing it back like
like really like look like you have two
ping pong balls
like focus on the two ping pong balls
themselves
oh repeatedly over and over again on the
actual two ping pong balls
and then realize that the same observer
is looking out of all of the other pairs
of ping pong balls around the planet
that's a shared str like a shared
thread coming from every single one of
those observers
and so then there's like an
all-inclusive awareness
that you can tap into more and more and
then if you recognize that
that one all-inclusive awareness is even
just like you know when you go to dream
at night
and you like enter your dream and you
simulate out the observer
and the reality for the observer
that is exactly what we are as source
that simulates the awareness that all
inclusive awareness
and the reality for it to immerse itself
into
so kind of like go back in your
perception over and
over and over again until you get to
the source of the all-inclusive
awareness
and so then you hit that very
nothingness and you hit the very
everythingness and then just kind of
just navigate that
abiding process but to have that style
of like a road map
has been for when i hit the ball back
for people has been good
just hone in again on the very
fact that you're aware and that
awareness is shared
among us all and that there you are the
source of the awareness
yeah and to me to me like color helps a
lot
uh you know depending on how you like
just how your brain is wired
but literally like just looking at black
you look at black
and instantly you can just recognize
like oh there it is
each time you blink you know it's like
oh look oh there it
you know it's where it's where it's
coming from it's where it's going to and
it's just recognizing that like every
moment
all the time and black is just you know
just because black it's like
you just see it just it's
it's it's beyond black you know it's the
reason you look at
like you you see black and then it's
because you go beyond it
and then you see the light on it and
it's like it's hitting
it's hitting you you know and so to be
able to go in and out and to go back and
forth and to go left and right
and any of that is like happening inside
almost this dark room
it's right here it's right here
oh there you go the black
it's just just the screen itself
yeah before it gets modulated
so yeah just like that so the very
screen itself
we all have the same pure bear
empty nothingness right and then
the awareness itself is like oh look at
atlas's
alice i got something that's going to
blow your mind what happens
go we ask the question ask the question
first then we'll go to brendan
ask the question okay cool so what
happens to me is
i got to the feeling of just awareness
right i've got in there
and then i'm like oh this is crazy you
know this is like
nothing type [ __ ] i guess um
but then it's like the mind kicks in
it's like all right what is awareness
what is you know i've also had the
feeling of
everything being awareness and then i
start questioning
okay then how come a tree doesn't think
like i
do or whatnot i started thinking these
crazy thoughts
and then it brings me back you know and
there's
i guess just that thought about black as
well you know so
that little thought just keeps putting
me back in man
i don't know who you're in this moment
that it feels done
it feels so dumb okay can i say
i feel like the way that me and you
respond to this situation of life is
very very similar
in the way where i'm an investigator too
and
the threshold that broke me between
absorption not absorption was just
in the deep state of meditation i am
awareness realizing my body
is the subject for my mind and my mind
is the subject for my body
and neither of them can be found in
either realm
so as you realize like christian murder
said the observer
is the observed the spiral tightens and
through that
investigative technique it can break
through the threshold
which atlas is talking about on the
other side
of just reminding yourself of i am i am
i am
we can talk about that more god [ __ ] but
i feel like that's the technique that
would be useful for you man it is that's
a good one yeah hold the talking stick
can you say one more thing of course of
course
let me go brendan yeah because we're
hitting we're hitting rome's point
and it's a help along yesterday this is
also just
like along the side it's like you know
it is it is it is literally like the
infinity sign
you know it is because like like he's
saying like the the body mind that
duality for me
for me that's i think what hit it the
most and i noticed it like because i
growing up i used to dance a lot
and even right now like i'm doing
kidneys but i'm noticing like okay
bodywork and like walking on grass
or breathing and like spending time in
the sun and these kinds of things like
and just noticing the difference between
you know
if i can see the sun on my eyelids
how does that affect my my whatever my
mind
and then and then where do my eyes go
after that
you know because of this happening where
do my eyes go after that and so it's
like
you know is it because of the sun being
on my eyelids that i looked
in that direction you know is it because
of
uh somebody in here who who wanted to
look there and and
by doing this you know it's it it is
inquiry at the same time but you're
investigating
like nate said it's like investigating
moment by moment all the time when you
just have some time you're just chilling
out
and you're like you know who's running
the ship
and from where yeah
no none of us have experienced the aha
moment
because no one can experience it because
it's attributeless
so so we're in the same boat man
i feel like i know all of that logically
you know like
logically i know that you you see it
who's here felt it before
but it's just that and now that's where
i'm at it's like
i'm trying to erase all logic and then
kind of like you guys said abide by
it or abide in it dude that's one i'm
saying logic is not
separate from it like logic is just
another you know it's a tool
that you can pick up and put down in
accordance with everything else
you know like i'm using words like
accordance and i
and i'm saying you know and you can
think of the music the musical
instrument accordion
and we're talking about logic you you
recognize
you know you recognize like these kinds
of things these kinds of
ideas about a left brain right brain a
masculine feminine
but these things aren't you know it's
not it was never like a
a dance art uh it's because of
recognizing that fluidity but also the
structure but also the chaos
but also the orderliness and it's it's
it's in seeing that
all the time you know recognizing like
when you fall
even that's choreographed and and it's
choreographed because you'll contract
it's when you when you fall you'll
notice the contraction and you'll
recognize
like oh my gosh i became so tight and so
small you're not falling anywhere
yeah exactly and and if anything if as
soon as you fall
just let it go it's gone
um can i can i yeah
yes so remember you had the phone right
and what were you saying speaking on the
phone the
the black screen yeah the very
nothingness that then
the awareness is experiencing the very
first
that's why you have a different phone
screen background each one of us does
right so that's the this is the very
nothingness and the very first
there it is yeah elmo see there you go
look at all these different
backgrounds right and you can mod you
there's infinite possibilities for
modulation
right so you can this one yep
um okay yeah so on that topic
check this out look in saraswati's hand
wait let me put you on the main screen
hold on all right
where do you want us to look on the hand
a croissant
oh no that's an oroboros
right here right here
what is you see that is that a phone
yes oh my gosh what
what the [ __ ] what
dude that's awesome dude that's insane
dude this is what i mean man this is
what i mean by breaking boundaries dude
why does saraswati need a phone
sarah swati likes to phone her homies
but man even that even calling others
is a plagiarism plagiarization of
telepathy as the boundaries dissolve
technology plagiarization even
all somebody is telepathy
ai is the technological copy of
awakening we are moving towards declare
violence
right go for it how do we
do okay so sound this this is always
tripping out this has nothing to do with
like
but sound so my vocal chords
are creating a frequency of vibration
coming out
and somebody outside of my car can't
hear me
in time space they're literally two feet
away and they won't hear me
but you guys are on the other side of
the whole entire universe
and my vibration from my vocal chords in
this place of space
[Music]
whoever created this [ __ ] isn't
enlightened you know is it [ __ ]
how's this all happening we
that's also one of the things is like
where is the beginning
where does it begin beginningless
beginningless
endless yeah that question
that question is an easy one to get
stuck on it happened for me for a couple
months
uh and then you let go of it and then
you're like oh my god that was so easy
it's just you can't because you can
always ask that question any moment
you know like think of it this way like
you find yourself in a situation that's
shitty and you're like [ __ ] man i'm just
having a horrible day you can ask
yourself
when did this begin when will it end
who is having a horrible day there you
go that's that's really the best
question is the best question is who am
i
or what is i and if you ask that
question repeatedly
to yourself that's like the osho said it
was the most revolutionary act and
in reference to the now who
now and then it creates that
oh that's good yeah who am i
in this be here now oh yeah and then
and then you see the whole field
my screen my bottle it's all reflecting
myself back to me
there's a question for each of us and it
is
how can we be present to our loved ones
uh how do you answer that that's a
beautiful question man
it's just already perfection so just be
present with them and for whatever
they share because if you're empty bliss
you're a mirror and so what's happening
is they're going to say something
and then what you do is you just hold
that beautiful
love light sun enlightenment energy
and then what you do is you just resp
it's and then it's just the
ineffable and it just flows right out of
emptiness
is the love and the compassion and the
peace but then if you
you know the whole thing with this is a
really interesting balancing thing is
if you become too martadom or
overzealous
with love what happens is you learn
through the sledgehammer of suffering
how to create distance with wisdom
so many people like when it said how do
i you know love my family or how do i
love
my friends or how do i how
how do i weave tantra my
realizations awaken realizations is
that you learn
how to be wise as well which is hey
maybe
you maybe you
stop pursuing what is no longer in your
north star trajectory if this is a lower
trajectory
you drop that trajectory and you only
pick up the phone
when you feel like it's more around
either service
or for more awakened people or whatnot
so if
somebody's still in a more egoic
tendency that's always trying to project
and always says need or lack or whatever
don't pick up don't meet with them drop
the connections
still yeah yeah that's can i go next can
i go on this one
so unless atlas you were talking about
meeting people just
being on a blister walk and telling them
like
is it being just beautiful
and that's the space you want to hold
for everybody because in that space you
realize that they're
we are all in it we're all just
marinating in
[ __ ] source and it's not
like being overzealous with love is
thinking that
some others are separate and you're
trying to bring them to the flock
and you're trying to be a shepherd for
them that's the jesus syndrome you just
you're it and i recognize you as it and
it's just
the simplest
being is the simplest thing
everybody has it everybody and that's
when you become
everyone's friend that's why
that's why loving kindness and and
compassion
and and karuna and mudita
yeah yeah that's it's it
you hold it for everything
every sensation you can hold it in the
palm
of loving kindness
or in the palm of mudita
yeah sound even an energetic jerk could
be held in
in that and and as soon as you hold it
in that as soon as you let go of it
you know you've let go of it in a way
that could never harm
neither you or
not you or
because you're not passing it on like
that well
you're just it's you you're you're
allowing it to stop
you yeah you're it's because of that
gentle hand
you're allowing it to dissolve into
where it needs to go rather than to
continue just
you know and you're not trying to
destroy it either that's why you don't
attack the clashes or the
the that ah his mind is you work with it
yes you don't attack it you work with it
it's all workable you can you can refine
it
because it's part of being human dude
the the the don't let the you could be
those wild horses you you don't like let
them run wild but you tame them and you
don't beat them
but you love them and tame them and you
ride them
yeah write them you lose the constant
seeking
because i realized that the other day
too um
just kind of being mindful um
that the mind is just constantly seeking
seeking seeking it never ends it just
seeks and sees and seeks
and it just needs to it's like
it needs something to like narrate of
some word
and i kind of separated from that as
well
and i realized i was so stupid too and
but then
i guess i'm in a place that i'm trying
like you said trying to beat the horse
i'm trying to beat the ego beat the mind
over time what i've noticed is that
even though the more restless
seeking impulse dissipates
then there's a very calm and loving
refining impulse so it's almost like
why do we have this conversation because
we're all refining
each other and we're sharing
in service to others as well and so
it's more about okay well even if you
get it
they're still as we said also an abiding
and purifying process
you can begin sort of very subtly
detecting when you're coming from your
egoic conditioning versus when you're
coming from god's love light
and so when you're sourceful when you're
coming from
source you can feel it it's a different
resonance
than when you come from a layer of lack
or need
or validation that type of stuff
so there's a there's a constant refining
process
that also happens purifying
you know to me can
guys do you guys ever feel like
very very very old old
and young at the same time
yeah i don't want this because they're
related to what rome is
because when you are is older than the
buddha
what was the last quote when you're as
old as the buddha
it's amazing yeah it's because i think
that's like the original face
because that's young and infinite at the
same time it's
because it's always renewed moment to
moment
yo but it has been renewing for infinity
so it's no
and have any any of you guys seen um
uh babaji yet
who babaji
yeah this is this was the
uh yogananda's lineage yes
[Music]
have you just joined it oh oh looks like
we just joined it
oh guys no
looks like we're public you know yes
yes yes you can have that kind of wisdom
and just
did you guys did you guys like uh see
this dude
we're seeing him we're seeing him dude
he found us yo babaji found us
yo what's that quote when the right time
the teacher comes and then
now and then the teacher leaves what's
right and this is getting a bit too
the student is ready the master appears
and when the student is truly ready the
master disappears disappears
yo you and you disappears and as soon as
you said that babaji disappeared
we did it
he blew him out i think
i think riley was the was the master
here
i think he was the one who was
you think what i think riley was the
best
i i didn't understand that what okay
hold on we have a question from the
audience
all right so we've been explaining this
in many
different ways but just very simply put
take an
object like a pen look at the object
realize that you're looking at an object
what
we call an object in what we say in
physical as an object
and then work your perception backwards
work your perception backwards to become
more and more aware of awareness itself
and become more and more aware of the
very source
of your awareness itself just go to the
big bang
go to the very big bang disappear into
the big bang just take it very simply
also from a scientific perspective
just disappear into the big bang think
about
the play of light on your very retina
think about the very
end point the very starting point
think about how everything comes out of
nothingness and goes back to nothingness
and if you want to take it even further
if you wanna if you just wanna drag the
investigation and the visualization just
to the edge
to see that your eyeball
is like the earth
with its stratosphere just
reflecting uv rays off of it
just the very fact that you could even
see that in your own eyeball
is more than enough to recognize that
it's not gonna
sources
check out that quote i'm posting it
right now it's a really good one
it's it's uh um one of them i think
also came from um
this is saint francis of saint francis
yeah yeah
the one you are looking for is the one
who is looking become
more and more aware that you are looking
for
awareness the nature of awareness is
peace and joy and you're trying to
extract it by getting
an object once i get that new upgraded
phone then i'll be happy no no no
the nature of your awareness itself
is peace and happiness so
there's a very big difference between
needing to extract
from the world and that's where
suffering happens just again become
aware of seeing
become aware of observation of
witnessing
become aware of the sock might actually
be
well we'll talk about that on our on our
show together but take
that outward that outwardness of the
sock
and go like this
like this
i'm curious what brendan has to say
because if he lit up on that question
you know today i was uh i was leaving
the front seat of my car
and my um and as i was leaving
um i left the car and then i just said
to my mom
oh and i i didn't know like i just lost
you know where
that where the car was above me and so
i just knew where my body was and i kind
of just sucked myself out of it
and i just remember telling my mom that
was literally like pulling a sock off
yep or you know when you enter a room
or you jump into something or try doing
a front roll just do a front roll
you just get on the grass and just do a
front roll and you'll see
like whoa dude that's it
what's wrong wrong yeah
do you a friend are we answering the
questions still how to get to the source
for me is for me it's always been the
realization of no separation
because we see space which is air as
separation like there is air between me
and the
laptop there's air between me and atlas
but in a way
infinite body are connected by the air
because whatever i breathe ends up
in all of your lungs
and that spirit that lives in us all
and it's the same thing but it's
nourishing different things different
growths
so that's how we are inseparable to
nature
and also a great visual visualization
for me is
go back into the energy from which you
were created
there you go go back into the moment
where
you were created when you were conceived
go back into the love that created you
that still lives as you go into
the love of your mother and father and
baskin you've got intermission
i think the moment you fall asleep
just the very edge of when you just
that and when you just just
see this spring of
waking up whether that be in a dream or
whether that be in here wherever that
may be
recognizing that over and over again and
just simply having the intention to
notice that
is
falling asleep is a great technique to
recognize source
maintaining awareness
yeah and you you learn how to
concentrate better too i think
because you you can in a sense learn to
like
put to sleep everything else other than
what you need to be awake
and in doing that single pointedness is
so much easier
resonating at the self-existent
luminosity
infusing of the threshold point between
wake and sleep
once we recognize that threshold we can
zoom in
to the apart impermanence of every
rising phenomenon
down to immediacy
my boys are really hitting some moves
right now
oh man
everybody watching right now become a
part of
this world become the tender that we are
enjoying the ocean elmo brings up a good
point is
viewers homies if you guys want join us
release the contracted energy through
movement movement movement
is medicine to me movement is the moment
you recognize
it's not even the moment man it's just
every time just
every movement every action every
intention just leaves a little trace in
your body
everywhere all the time and so just
seeing that
and recognizing it and allowing it to do
its little dance around your spine and
around your
neck and around your shoulder your trap
all the way down all the way up
it's yoga
i love this octopus
elmo looks like a kid in
a in a ball pit
that would be like swimming in there
like
i remember this one time i was playing
pool and i was just thinking what if
inside inside each of these pool balls
is
is a whole dimension unto itself with
its own world system and ecosystem and
planets and beings
and what if they're all cheering on this
game right now as we're playing this
game of pool
basically
but every cell is uh
its own oh hey let's answer this yeah
quick question
from the audience so i love that
question
yeah so first of all everything's
already ineffably perfect
and so we've become addicted to
in a sense our conditioning and our
egoic
twists and distortions and nonsense and
so because of that we invented this word
called spirituality
which is realigning ourselves away from
the egoic
distortions towards what is
source coming from source coming from
nothingness and everythingness and pure
service
as you see everything as god's love
light
interacting with itself so you don't
try and extract peace and happiness from
the world but you bring it to
all experiences you decondition and
deprogram
yourself from your onion layers so we
invented it as a concept as a word
to
the earlier question completely cascades
into this question
how to recognize source because what's
the point
completely aims at where the
phase space of the paradox kisses what
is the point
that the no self which we talk about
every
display can only be characterized by
the attributes of it and so the
pointlessness of it is the
the point so regardless if you're a
self-inquiry person or if you're
in the stock exchange trying to
actualize the most that you are
you're either gonna play the game until
you're gonna lose
right or and spin back or you're gonna
play the game until you're gonna win and
spin back
and um so the point is the pointlessness
there is no point that's the
pointlessness
so we don't need to justify it because
you can't
justify it because justifying it is it
that's right no malevolence no suffering
when people awaken
and yeah that's a great way to put it
sock man
great way to put it
what's the point bro
i mean that's why depression really
cascades into it so what's the point
is the effortlessness of it and freedom
from
nihilism which is yeah yeah yeah yeah
philosophical step when you've gone
through all uh all of the other
like viewpoints they're like none of
this [ __ ] matters
and then it's
[Music]
i got that i'm the dj yeah i just want
to say
when you also come from source you
realize that this
is your anarchic creative fireworking
so [ __ ] love it yeah
and your being matters
you're being here now matters you matter
everybody who's [ __ ] listening you
matter your body your
feelings your heart actually matters
have them have them go back to the
source
of their being have them go back to the
source of their essence
of their being being
beating what is being beating right now
the source of their
[Music]
oh
the others
[Music]
this is another great question
yes the suffering of the apparent person
matters which is why once you awaken
buddha the
awakened one you weave that together
with
atlas the one that takes the burden
of being coming in pure service you do
the bodhisattva
instead of abiding constantly in
nothingness
what you do is you refocus physically
to awaken to maximize prosperity
and abundance because it's you that's
suffering in another costume
when you lighten others you lighten the
load on yourself
yeah and the body yeah all the time the
body
takes the whole world and does vows to
liberate himself
that he is the weight that he is
carrying it's it's that it's that
it's that uh it's frank yang's 99.9
percent self that wasn't liberated that
decided to ask the rest of him
to liberate himself for the sake of
everyone else
for the sake of concern
but that's just one stick opposite end
service to
ultimate service to sell with ultimately
ultimate surges to others and the same
thing it's a loop
because the stick is just a circle
you can twist it
but the best way to create polarity is
to become
in service to others and then that helps
you
balance out your purification and
then it ends up being service to self
in the end of things anyway versus when
you start in service to self
you don't do it from a pure perspective
you're doing it from a very
extractionary
i would say though like for anybody who
has
you know for me like i think my own
realizations i had
so many and each time i was just like
man it's just
fun and like so many times just waking
up
and if you don't have the compassion for
yourself
uh even whether you know the egoic
identity is not
an enemy ever and to think that it is is
like
just more ego games we use it for our
awakening
ego is our best tool for it exactly yeah
all right i'm gonna wrap with
this of course
just relax everyone relax
relax your perspective
yes take those deep breaths
relax your perspective and stop
describing your experience and just
relax into the very essence that you are
the very fact that you are
is a sign that you are worthy
it's a sign that you are the source
the inexhaustible well expressing itself
as you as a firework of the infinite
so just relax relax your perspective
don't describe your experience
and just breathe breathe into being for
about a minute
into the ineffable perfection that we
already are
so atlas
we're just breathing right now
your very existence right now is perfect
[Music]
fall in complete love with yourself
exactly as you are
knock knock knocking on heaven
accept yourself
knock knock knock
your unique spark of the infinite
i'm not knocking on the head
realize you are the one infinite creator
knock knock knocking on heaven's
[Music]
infinite possibility
you can't not be perfect
so relax and surrender
[Music]
we love you
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
all right so that's zen phams
[Music]
love you guys adore you
[Music]
so
you